i
[Música]
ah
en el día internacional contra la
desaparición forzada decenas de
colectivos se movilizaron en varios
estados de méxico para exigir acciones
que permitan localizar a más de 90.000
personas integrantes del movimiento por
nuestros desaparecidos se plantaron
frente a palacio nacional en demanda de
medidas más contundentes la fiscalía
general de la república informó que a la
fecha investiga la desaparición de más
de 2.600 personas mientras que el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
se reunió con familiares y
sobrevivientes de la llamada guerra
sucia de los años 70 y acordaron la
creación de un mecanismo de una comisión
presidencial de justicia verdad memoria
reparación y no repetición en tanto la
cancillería dio a conocer que en cuanto
a la pandemia lo permita el comité de la
1 contra la desaparición forzada
realizará una primera visita en el país
el comité internacional de la cruz roja
para mexico advirtió que les preocupa la
seguridad de las familias que buscan a
sus desaparecidos
colombia recordó a sus desaparecidos en
el día internacional de las personas
desaparecidas con varios actos oficiales
y civiles en múltiples municipios del
país por ejemplo en bogotá a las madres
y familiares de los conocidos como
'falsos positivos' reivindicaron en la
céntrica plaza de bolívar la memoria de
sus hijos 6 mil 400 jóvenes ejecutados
por el ejército y presentados como bajas
guerrilleras los cuerpos de la mayoría
de ellos todavía no han sido encontrados
lo mismo ocurre con las más de 80.000
personas desaparecidas que se registran
en colombia' tras más de 50 años de
conflicto armado el centro nacional de
memoria histórica atribuye casi la mitad
de estas desapariciones a los grupos
paramilitares mientras que calcula que
la guerrilla fue responsable del 20 por
ciento de los crímenes el acuerdo de paz
que se firmó en 2016 entre la antigua
guerrilla de las farc y el gobierno dio
esperanza a los familiares al crear
órganos específicos para la búsqueda de
los desaparecidos sin embargo la tarea
avanza con lentitud debido en gran parte
a la falta de recursos y a la violencia
que persiste en el país
el fantasma de las desapariciones volvió
a colombia con el estallido social del
paro nacional del mes de abril la
fiscalía todavía busca a 91 personas que
desaparecieron durante las
manifestaciones
en argentina en el día internacional de
las víctimas de desapariciones forzadas
una serie de actos conmemorativos
enfocados especialmente en las
desapariciones que tuvieron lugar
durante la dictadura militar que gobernó
el país entre 1976 y 1983 hubo un evento
oficial en buenos aires frente al río de
la plata' en el parque de la memoria que
contiene un monumento en forma de largos
muros con placas con los nombres de las
personas desaparecidas y asesinadas
durante ese gobierno de facto y otros
eventos en distintos lugares que
funcionaron como centros de detención
del gobierno militar y se han convertido
en espacios de memoria como el que se
encuentra en la ex escuela de mecánica
de la armada en buenos aires donde una
de las calles internas del predio fue
rebautizada con el nombre son 30.000 en
referencia al número de personas
desaparecidas durante la última
dictadura militar
[Música]